[Music]
we're sleep she's gone and so is
everyone else wait a minute where the
hell do you think you're going away from
me out this place discuss it off the
brain you all do the same
don't walk away from me where's Selena
where's Dan I spent 25 years cooking for
these uppity [ __ ]
I'm not about to die from bad [ __ ] I
know things seem far beyond your control
right now but such that it is for all of
us here I shall take my leave and I
employ you my friends die in this
godforsaken house and if you are too
much of a coward to do the same you
would best before I kill you myself
scoping on here
I know he's in pain and I know you might
be too but we need to leave this place
there's only death here
[Music]
there's one I've been meaning to ask you
some question what is this
the detectives been keeping tabs on us
the detectives did keeping tabs on me in
Saline he's the one who orchestrated all
of this he did this detector detector
where is he he took them from me and
took my friends from me where is he you
hiding from me choose your next words
carefully colonel you sir no friend of
mine who you want to talk about friends
you anybody this is madness you want to
talk about madness madness is stealing
your best friend's wife madness is
squeezing you for cash to fund your own
sick sexual exploits with that very
woman shut up
madness is plotting the death your
childhood friend because you cannot
[Music]
he took everything he trapped us in here
for this broken Sheldon and we played
right into his he guessed he'd been
planning for two years and now that son
of a [ __ ] is out there walking around
look I know you have questions they
can't answer everything right now just
know that Lara took everything from us
first twisted quest of vengeance but
death does not boast the same same
fancies this doesn't have to be you're
trapped in here just to saves us but
it's your body broken baby it's still
out there laughing marks not the only
one that you will use as you please to
his benefit the same way that I brought
you here is the same way that I can send
you back but you can't survive
from the Colonel's autograph you can't
blame him honestly he's a good man he's
dangerous I know this is honestly I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going is
what is wrong but I know that I trust
and if you trust us together you have a
choice you just know that this is the
only way that you skate just relax
this almost Christmas I promise
oh no it's okay I thought you were dead
I I mean of course they're not dead how
could you be dead I wouldn't have kills
you
I I didn't kill you I mean if I didn't
kill anybody
it was all a joke of course there's
always hope were you in on this
the Damien put you up to this of course
he did
[Music]
[Applause]